hey guys welcome to a quick tutorial and
explanation about 32-bit Python vs.
64-bit Python some of the hurdles you'll
have to deal with whether whichever one
you use if you're on a 32-bit operating
system none of those really matters
meant to you right now cuz you're not
gonna be able to use 64-bit anyways but
you might still want to stick around
learn a few things just in case you ever
do get a 64-bit system in the future
let's talk about some real basics real
quick what are the what are the
differences between 32 and 64-bit when
it comes to python basically the major
difference here at least performance
wise is gonna be your memory allowance
with a 32-bit program the maximum amount
of RAM that can be allocated is two
gigabytes for program so depending what
kind of work you use Python for this
might not ever be an issue for you if
you ever embark on like Big Data kind of
stuff then this two gigabyte limit is
just pretty much going to stop you from
being able to do that so there's that
functionally there's some back-end
differences between 32-bit in 64-bit as
well and this will basically stop you
from being able to intermix these two
things okay sounds you know easy enough
right I'll just get the 64-bit operating
system and the 64-bit Python we'll be
good to go right well not quite many of
the Python modules are actually 64 I
mean 32-bit only even some of these like
most popular ones so for a great example
of this is if you are into doing big
data manipulation or huge like
mathematic problems then you're gonna
quickly find out that numpy is one of
those modules it's 32-bit only well we
just can't win can't wait doesn't but
you can there are actually a few options
you can custom edit registry keys and
the install paths which I really don't
suggest you start doing unless you're
very comfortable with it and either way
you better make some backups for you
anything with those registry values also
this isn't gonna really solve everything
every time you might still be able to
install the file
well then I want to actually operate as
expected sometimes next you could
rebuild or recompile the import or
module if you have the source files or
you can go the easiest route and that's
to be to go to this website lfd dot you
see I too
edu and some Python lib stuff I'll put a
link in the description for anyone who
needs it but this website has basically
all is 64-bit imports and modules you
can ever want I love this stuff so on
here these are well this is like the
list of everything they have but as you
can see they've got everything all your
installers for 64-bit they also have
some 32-bit on I don't know every time I
visited this page it was because I
needed a 64-bit installer but anyway
they've got all these imports here so
basically for like some of the stuff I
just did like this base map projection
stuff like that if people had the
regular vanilla installation of like
matplotlib they probably had a 32-bit
pil installation and you needed to get
the 64-bit pil anyway kind of a mess
same thing with if you try to do numpy
in the 32-bit or I mean app numpy with a
64-bit Python not gonna work so you can
get numpy from here anyway there's just
huge list up in the link in description
so if you guys need 64-bit versions of
various Python imports and modules don't
give up your 64-bit Python and your you
know forfeit and go down to a two
gigabyte limit lieu that sucks you can
use this website and I'm not sure this
guy's like a donate button or what I
don't see any donate button on here but
if you own this website you should put a
donate button on here I would donate to
you anyway
that's gonna be all for this tutorial
just want to show you guys that have a
nice day